Imagine living in the heart of that city.
Waking up to stunning waterfront views,...
...competing in venues you can see from your bedroom.
All just a short walk from some of the coolest parts of a city...
...that is a world capital of youth culture.
This is what athletes can look forward to in Tokyo.
As an athlete, I am proud to say our views have been taken on board.
So, for example, the village will be the center of our games both in spirit and geography.
Athletes from every country will also enjoy passionate support...
...from Japanese fans who really know sport, and appreciate fair play.
Last summer, more than five hundred thousand took to the streets of Tokyo on a weekday...
...to celebrate with us London 2012 athletes.
Just look at the pictures and imagine that passion in 2020.
Every venue will be filled.
Every sport will sparkle.
Tokyo will deliver an incredible platform for the promotion of the Olympic movement.
Promotion that will go hand in hand with worldwide appeal of Japan's youth culture...
...whose animated heroes inspired real life stars such as Messi, Kaka and Uchimura,...
...as well as many children, in many countries, to take up their favorite sport.
And promotion also based on innovation.
Imagine technology such as next generation motion tracking...
...in sports presentation, in live sites and more.
All to connect more young people with sport so that they, like me,...